un problema clásico de diferenciación
implícita es este cuando tenemos que
james que es igual a x elevado a la
equis y entonces definir cuál es la
derivada de con respecto a x y cuando
ven esto de x elevado a la x como esta
potencia no es una constante pues no se
sabe qué regla de potencia es elegir el
truco aquí es bastante simple es
realizar el logaritmo natural en ambos
lados de esta igualdad y esto lo
desarrollaremos un poquito más adelante
en el vídeo si sacan el logaritmo
natural de ambos lados de esta ecuación
vamos a tener logaritmo natural de jay
es igual a logaritmo natural de x a la x
ahora nuestra regla de potencias o las
reglas del logaritmo natural nos dice
que si tengo algo elevado a otro algo va
a ser equivalente a voy a reescribir
este logaritmo natural de x a la x como
x por el logaritmo natural de x
así que vamos a reescribir todo esto de
nuevo al tomar el logaritmo natural en
ambos lados de la ecuación
logaritmo natural de igual ahora x
logaritmo natural de x y ahora podemos
tomar la derivada con respecto a x en
ambos lados de esta ecuación
aquí en ambos lados y ahora vamos a
aplicar la regla de la cadena la regla
de la cadena nos dice que cuál es la
derivada de esto con respecto a x pues
va a ser la derivada de nuestra función
interna con respecto a x es una
diferenciación implícita
con respecto a x multiplicada por la
derivada de todo esto con respecto a
esta función interna por ejemplo
logaritmo natural de x es 1 / x así que
logaritmo natural de lleva a ser 1 entre
el organismo natural de ye con respecto
a lleva a ser 1 / i
y esto es igual a la derivada de esto
que es la regla del producto y que voy a
cambiar colores aquí arbitrariamente es
la derivada del primer término 1 por el
segundo término el logaritmo natural de
x más la derivada del segundo término
que es 1 / x ahora el primer término que
es x
y así tenemos
con respecto a x x 1 / y que es igual a
logaritmo natural de x
+ x entre x es 11 y ahora multiplicamos
ambos lados por jay y nos queda la
derivada de que con respecto a x es
igual a ye por el logaritmo natural de x
+ 1 y si no les gusta estar aquí se
pueden ser la sustitución ya que es
igual a x elevado a la x así que podemos
sustituir esta derivada de con respecto
a x es igual a x elevado a la x x
logaritmo natural de x más 1 y es un
problema bastante divertido de realizar
y a veces lo ponen como un problema con
truco o como un problema extra para
realizar pero nos han dado un problema
todavía más difícil y es lo que vamos a
realizar a continuación pero les quise
mostrar este problema resuelto primero
porque nos da las herramientas básicas
para resolver el siguiente
así que este problema difícil que vamos
a resolver es este
el problema es
es igual a x elevado
a la equis se hubiese elevado a la equis
así que tenemos que encontrar la
derivada de ye con respecto a x bueno
para resolver esto decimos que vamos a
usar las mismas herramientas que vimos
en el ejemplo anterior usar el logaritmo
natural en ambos lados para descomponer
este problema y dejarlo en términos con
los que podemos trabajar así que vamos a
usar la regla del producto
hacemos el organismo natural en ambos
lados de esta ecuación igual que la vez
pasada el logaritmo natural de ye que es
igual a el logaritmo natural de
x elevado a la x a la x
así que aplicamos esto podemos
reescribirlo como x a la x x el
logaritmo natural
de x
no esta expresión queda simplificada
como el logaritmo natural de g
que es igual a equis a la equis por el
logaritmo natural de x pero aún tenemos
esta x a la equis aquí en medio frita ya
que no sabemos una forma fácil para
hacer la derivada de esta parte pero me
acabo de dar cuenta que ya antes en este
vídeo he resuelto cuál es la derivada de
x a la x así que lo puedo simplemente
sustituir aunque podría también aplicar
de nuevo logaritmo natural de todo esto
pero esto ya lo hice antes de hecho lo
vemos y aquí está es esto de acá así que
simplemente nos acordamos esto y los
objetivos aquí
vamos a resolver entonces nuestro
problema y fíjense curiosamente ya
habíamos resuelto esto con anticipación
es un beneficio extra de haber hecho
este ejemplo previo aunque como les digo
podríamos seguir aplicando logaritmo
natural en ambos lados aunque sería
quizás un poquito complicado pero ya
tenemos esto así que pues para que
complicarnos más la vida
la derivada en ambos lados de la
ecuación con respecto a x
y la derivada con respecto a x de esto
esto lo tachamos
la derivada de eso con respecto a x la
derivada del logaritmo natural de y con
respecto a g
1 / i
x la derivada de g con respecto a x
con respecto x la regla de la cadena y
todo esto va a ser igual
la derivada del primer término
multiplicado por el segundo término
bueno lo voy a escribir para no obviar
pasos aquí derivada con respecto a x de
el primer término x al x x el algoritmo
natural de x más la derivada con
respecto a x de el logaritmo natural de
x x x a la x
vamos a resolver esto cuál es la
derivada de x a la x
bueno es lo que ya resolvimos
anteriormente aquí
es x a la x por el algoritmo natural de
x1
lo escribimos aquí
vamos a hacerlo en otro color esto de
aquí se me olvidó que era gay xx
laborismo natural de x 1 x la x x el
logaritmo natural de x + 1
y lo vamos a multiplicar por el
logaritmo natural de x
y logremos natural de x
y vamos a sumarle
esto y la derivada de logremos natural
de x que eso es bastante directo 1 / x x
x alaix x a la x
y por supuesto el lado izquierdo de la
ecuación es uno entre gente de x
multiplicamos ambos lados de esta
cuestión porque nos queda de ella entre
de x
con respecto a x es igual a x todo esto
xx por el logaritmo natural de x + 1
por el logaritmo natural de x + 1
1 / x x x elevado en la equis pero esto
de aquí es x a la menos 1 así que
podemos reescribir todo esto como x a la
x menos 1 si no les gusta esta y podemos
sustituir la por lo que tenemos aquí ya
sabemos que es igual a x elevado a la x
a la x así que nuestra solución final
para este problema que por un lado
pareciera muy sencillo pero cuando nos
damos cuenta de lo que implica se nos
hace muy complicado nos queda como la
derivada de y con respecto a x igual
allí que ya es esto nos suscribimos x
elevado a la x a la x x todo esto
le voy a poner otro color
x x ala x por el logaritmo natural de x
+ 1
por lo mismo natural de x
x elevado a la x menos 1 así que vas a
quien lo hubiera dicho a veces las
matemáticas son muy elegantes cuando
hacen la derivada de algo obtienen un
resultado muy bonito como la derivada
del logaritmo natural que si fuera
logaritmo natural de x el resultado es 1
/ x que es bastante simple y elegante
pero a veces tratamos de hacer la
operación de algo que luce bastante
sencillo y obtenemos este tipo de
resultados medio locos pero este fue un
problema bastante interesante